WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> Reporter: I DID SPEAK WITH
JAMIE RASKIN, ONE OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND ASKED WHO
ARE YOU LOOKING AT ISSUING
CRIMINAL REFERRALS TO?
HE WOULD NOT GO THAT FAR.
HE SAID DECISIONS ARE STILL
BEING DISCUSSED EXACTLY WHO WILL
GET REFERRED TO BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
BUT HE DID SAY THE FOCUS OF THE
COMMITTEE IS ON THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT THE CENTER OF THE EVENTS
AND WHO MASTERMINDED THE ATTACK
ON CONGRESS AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT ON THAT DAY.
SO VERY LIKELY DONALD TRUMP WILL
BE ON THE LIST.
PEOPLE AROUND DONALD TRUMP,
PEOPLE WHO ARE -- THE COMMITTEE
HAS, OF COURSE, HEARD A LOT OF
TESTIMONY ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
THIS WILL ALL CULMINATE IN A
REPORT THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
PUT OUT AFTER ITS EXHAUSTIVE
INVESTIGATION FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS, MORE THAN THOUSAND OR SO
WITNESSES, THE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
ALL PUT TOGETHER IN A REPORT,
RASKIN TOLD ME THEY ARE MAKING
GREAT PROGRESS IN FINISHING THE
REPORT AND DOES NOT KNOW IF IT
WILL BE DONE THIS WEEK BUT OF
COURSE CONSIDERED TO BE DONE
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS
BECAUSE COME JANUARY 3rd WHEN
REPUBLICANS TAKE POWER THIS
COMMITTEE'S JOB AND ITS WORK IS
OVER.
>> SO THERE IS REAL TIME
PRESSURE AND THEY KNOW THIS AS
WELL AS EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS SURROUNDING
ALL OF THIS, ELLIOT.
YOUR REACTION TO LEARNING THAT
THERE WILL BE AT LEAST ONE
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
WE COULD SAY MUCH MORE DETAIL IS
NEEDED ON WHOM AND WHAT.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY, KATE.
SO A FEW THING, NUMBER ONE, AS
MANU SAID, THIS IS A STATEMENT
FROM CONGRESS, RIGHT.
IT DOES NOT ACTUALLY CARRY LEGAL
WEIGHT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOESN'T
HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, DOESN'T HAVE
TO ADHERE TO IT.
AS WE'VE SEEN ALREADY THEY'VE
GONE AHEAD WITH PROSECUTION.
LOOK, AS A STATEMENT IT'S A
PRETTY POWERFUL ONE THAT THEY
BELIEVE A CRIME WAS COMMITTED
AND MAYBE EVEN MORE POWERFUL BY
THE FACT THAT THEY ANNOUNCED IT
THE MORNING MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WERE GETTING
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDALS FOR
THEIR VALOR ON JANUARY 6th.
THAT WAS, I THINK, NOT AN
ACCIDENT AT ALL.
AND A VERY EFFECTIVE BIT OF
STAGECRAFT ON THE PART OF THE
COMMITTEE.
NOW, YOU KNOW, WHAT COULD IT BE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY FROM
WATCHING THE HEARINGS IT APPEARS
THAT WITNESS TAMPERING OR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT A-- JUSTICE.
ANYONE WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN CONCERT WITH COULD BE
REFERRED FOR A CRIME -- FOR A
CRIMINAL OFFENSE.
FINALLY LAST THING, IT'S NOT
JUST CRIMES HERE THAT CAN BE
REFERRED.
FOR INSTANCE, INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ATTORNEYS COULD BE REFERRED
TO BAR ASSOCIATIONS AND PUT
THEIR LAW LICENSE IN JEOPARDY IF
THEY ENGAGED IN MISCHIEF OR
WRONGDOING.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A POWERFUL
STATEMENT BY KJS.
>> ELLIOT, THIS COULD GET TO
REALLY WHAT HAS -- IF YOU SUM IT
ALL UP, AND IT IS HARD TO
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN A VAST
INVESTIGATION, AS MANU WAS
GETTING AT, THIS COULD GET TO
THE ABSOLUTE CORE AND KEY
QUESTION THAT IS REALLY WONDERED
SINCE THE BEGINNING, WHICH IS
WILL THIS LEAD TO IN THEIR
REPORT OR SEPARATELY THIS
COMMITTEE URGING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO PROSECUTE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP?
NOW, WE KNOW FROM PREVIOUS
REPORTING, ELLIOT, THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DIVIDED ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO PUT FORTH A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL AGAINST THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, BUT THE
INVESTIGATION IS ALSO SHOWN AND
THEY HAVE MADE CLEAR THEY
BELIEVE HE IS AT THE CENTER OF
ALL OF THIS SO WOULD YOU IN THE
END BE SURPRISED -- SURPRISED IF
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT AMONG THE
PEOPLE WHO THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AGAINST, THAT THEY GIVE
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE
SURPRISING IF THEY DIDN'T BASED
ON THE EVIDENCE THEY PUT OUT AND
TAPES THEY MADE AND WHERE IT
SEEMS THE COMMITTEE IS GOING BUT
LET'S BE CLEAR, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS ALREADY BEING
INVESTIGATED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THEY'RE ON THE RECORD ABOUT THAT
SO EVEN INDEPENDENT OF -- THIS
WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATION, YOU KNOW, OF A
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
BUT AT THE END THE DAY THE
PRESIDENT IS ALREADY IN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TROUBLE
POTENTIALLY AS IT IS BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT.
IF YOU HEAR WHAT THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE SAYING, CERTAINLY
THEY ARE DEBATING IT ROBUSTLY
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHICH
WAY TO PROCEED.
I'D BE SHOCKED IF HE WASN'T BUT,
AGAIN, MANY PEOPLE AROUND HIM
OUGHT TO ALSO BE CAUTIOUS AND
WORRIED RIGHT NOW.
>> AND, MANU, WHAT IS YOUR
EXPECTATION OF WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
BENNIE THOMPSON COMES OUT AND
SAYS THIS IS GOING TO COME BUT
SARA MURRAY IS LAYING OUT
LACKING ALL SORTS OF DETAIL
THAT'S REQUIRED TO REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE TRUE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS.
WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HOW THOMPSON
KIND OF IS ROLLING THIS OUT?
>> WELL, THEY'RE STILL MEETING
AND DISCUSSING SOME OF THEIR
FINAL DECISIONS AND RASKIN SAYS
MEETINGS ARE HAPPENING TONIGHT
INTO THE NEXT FEW DAYS AS THEY
TRY TO FINALIZE THE LANGUAGE,
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE REFERRED TO
IN THE CRIMINAL COMPLAINT BUT
JUST THE CONCLUSIONS THAT ALL OF
THE EVIDENCE LEADS TO.
THEY ARE WORKING ON ALL OF THAT
AND WHICH THEY BELIEVE THEY MADE
GREAT PROGRESS ON.
THERE ARE OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
TOO, WHAT DO THEY DO ABOUT THE
SUBPOENAS ISSUED TO REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS INCLUDING
KEVIN McCARTHY WHO MIGHT BE THE
NEXT SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE?
THEY HAVE NOT MADE ANY DECISIONS
YET ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT TO DO
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THOSE
REPUBLICANS DEFIED THOSE
SUBPOENAS.
THEY HAD SUGGESTED PERHAPS THAT
THERE COULD BE A REFERRAL TO THE
ETHICS COMMITTEE, MAYBE EVEN A
REFERRAL TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BUT THOSE QUESTIONS
STILL UNRESOLVED AT THIS HOUR.
CNN SARA MURRAY IS LIVE FOR US
ON CAPITOL HILL.
ELIE HONIG JOINS US.
WHAT DID THE CHAIRMAN SAY, AND
WHAT COMES NEXT?
>> Reporter: LOOK, HE SAID THAT
THEY WILL BE MAKING CRIMINAL
REFERRALS AND THAT THAT HAS BEEN
DECIDED BUT HE DIDN'T HAVE A LOT
OF OTHER DETAILS TO FILL OUT
ABOUT.
I ASKED IF HE'S NARROWED DOWN
THE UNIVERSE OF INDIVIDUALS
THEY'RE CONSIDERING.
HE SAID THEY HAD NOT.
WE KNOW THEY HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT POTENTIAL EVIDENCE OF
PERJURY, POTENTIAL EVIDENCE OF
WITNESS TAMPERING OR OBSTRUCTION
BUT DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S GOING
TO BE THE BASIS FOR THEIR
REFERRALS.
THEY WANT TO MAKE IT PUBLIC AND
WANT TO DO THIS QUICKLY BUT
THEY'RE NOT THERE YET.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
SIGNS THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
TRYING TO WATER DOWN THE NEWS
THE CHAIRMAN MADE TODAY.
WE GOT A STATEMENT FROM A
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE COMMITTEE
SAYING THEY'VE DETERMINED THAT
REFERRALS TO OUTSIDE ENTITIES
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THE FINAL WORK.
SO IT'S CLEAR THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY ARE STILL WORKING ON
THE DETAILS OF AND WE'RE
EXPECTING THE COMMITTEE TO BE
MEETING LATER TODAY TO SIFT
THROUGH SOME OF THESE DETAILS.
>> SARA, STAY WITH US.
ELIE, COME INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
DEAL WITH THIS QUESTION FIRST
THEN I'LL GET TO THE PROCESS AND
WHETHER IT MATTERS IF IT'S A
SPECIFIC REFERRAL OR NOT IN A
MOMENT.
BASED ON EVERYTHING WE HEARD
PUBLICLY AT THE HEARINGS, IF YOU
WERE A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
TEAM WITH YOUR PROSECUTION
BACKGROUND, WHO WOULD YOU PUT ON
THE LIST OF POSSIBLE REFERRALS?
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO START WITH
DONALD TRUMP, JOHN.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
COMMITTEE ESTABLISHED QUITE
CLEARLY THAT ALL OF THIS
HAPPENED BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP
WITH DONALD TRUMP'S KNOWLEDGE
AND TO SOME EXTENT WITH WHAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS HOPING TO
ACCOMPLISH.
ALSO, LET'S KEEP IN MIND THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN SORT OF CLEAR
ABOUT THEIR LIST OF THE USUAL
SUSPECTS.
IN FACT, IN THEIR SUBPOENA TO
DONALD TRUMP THEY SAID WE'RE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN YOUR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH JEFFREY
CLARK, JOHN EASTMAN, MICHAEL
FLYNN, STEVE BANNON, ROGER STONE
SO I'D LOOK TO SEE IF THEY NAMED
THEM AS WELL.
>> SARA, WHEN YOU GO UP ON THE
HILL, WE DO KNOW CONGRESSWOMAN
CHENEY HAS HAD A PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON DONALD TRUMP SO I THINK
ELIE IS RIGHT, YOU'D HAVE TO PUT
THAT TO THE TOP OF THE LIST.
IS IT GOING TO BE WE BELIEVE
CRIMES HAPPENED HERE AND YOU
SHOULD LOOK AT OUR REPORT OR WE
BELIEVE A, B, C AND D COMMITTED
CRIMES AND HERE'S THE EVIDENCE.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WAITING TO
SEE HOW SPECIFIC THEY ARE GOING
TO GET.
WHAT WE KNOW THE COMMITTEE IS
REALLY UNDER A TIME CRUNCH HERE.
THEY HAVE ESSENTIALLY A COUPLE
OF WEEKS LEFT TO FINISH THEIR
WORK TO GET TO NAIL DOWN THESE
CRIMINAL REFERRALS AND MAKE
THEM, TO FINISH THEIR FINAL
REPORT AND I THINK THAT THEY ARE
STILL GRAPPLING WITH WHAT
EXACTLY THIS DOCUMENT WOULD LOOK
LIKE THAT HAS TO DO WITH
CRIMINAL REFERRAL, JOHN.
>> WHEN A DOCUMENT LIKE THAT
GETS TO THE WHITE HOUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO SAY YET
BUT IS THERE A LEGAL REQUIREMENT
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
TO LOOK AT IN A CERTAIN WAY OR
ANOTHER BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
WHICH DID A VERY THOROUGH AND
IMPORTANT INVESTIGATION SENDING
ALONG ITS ADVICE AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CAN TAKE IT OR LEAVE
IT?
>> IT'S THE LATTER, JOHN.
A POLITICAL STATEMENT BY
CONGRESS OVER TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT'S A CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
PROSECUTORS GET CRIMINAL
REFERRALS ALL DAY EVERY DAY FROM
EVERY TYPE OF OUTSIDE ENTITY SO
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE DOJ TO DO
ANYTHING.
IN FACT, WE ALREADY KNOW DOJ IS
INVESTIGATING, MERRICK GARLAND
CONFIRMED THAT WHEN HE APPOINTED
JACK SMITH TO OVERSEE THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATIONS BUT THAT SAID
WHAT THE COMMITTEE COULD BE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS, ONE, PUT A
CAPSTONE ON THEIR WORK, PUT A
SORT OF STRONG CONCLUSIVE
STATEMENT TO WHAT THEY'VE DONE
AND, TWO, COULD BE TRYING TO GET
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC USED TO THE
IDEA OF A POTENTIAL INDICTMENT
OF A FORMER PRESIDENT.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL AND FROM DOJ'S
POINT OF VIEW COULD BE THAT THE
MORE PEOPLE HEAR THIS FROM THE
MORE AUTHORITATIVE SOURCES, IT
COULD BECOME LESS OF AIR SHOCK
IF AND WHEN THERE COMES A DAY
WHEN THEY DO INDICT TRUMP.
>> AND, SARA, TO BUTTON IT UP ON
CAPITOL HILL, THE COMMITTEE IN
ITS PUBLIC HEARINGS WAS
REMARKABLY UNIFIED.
THE DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
WORKING VERY WELL TOGETHER.
IT SEEMS AS IF ESPECIALLY WITH
BENNIE THOMPSON THE CHAIRMAN
SAYING THERE WILL BE REFERRALS
AND THE COMMITTEE TRYING TO
CLEAN IT UP ARE WE SEEING IN THE
END GETTING TO THE FINISH LINE,
THERE ARE MORE DIVIDES AND
DEBATES AMONG THE MEMBERS BUT
THEY EXIST?
>> Reporter: I THINK WE'RE
SEEING SOMETIMES WE SEE THE
CHAIRMAN GET A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER AHEAD OF WHERE THE REST
OF THE COMMITTEE MAY BE READY TO
BE ON PUBLIC ANNOUNCEMENTS.
I THINK THEY HAD THIS MEETING
SCHEDULED FOR LATER TODAY.
I THINK THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE EXPECTED TO GO IN
AND CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT CRIMINAL REFERRALS BUT,
LOOK, I THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY HAVE MADE
CLEAR THEY WANT TO DO AS A
UNIFIED COMMITTEE.
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO CRIMINAL
REFERRALS, WHOEVER THEY MAY
DECIDE TO PUT ON THAT LIST, THEY
CLEARLY WANT TO PUT A UNIFIED
FRONT FORWARD AND I THINK THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHY WE'RE GETTING SO
FEW DETAILS ABOUT WHO WAS ON THE
LIST, WHAT PROVIDE TENSION
CRIMES ARE ON THE LIST AND WANT
TO PRESENT A UNITED FRONT WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT FINAL DOCUMENT.
>> WE WILL CIRCLE BACK WHEN WE
GET THOSE DETAILS.
APPRECIATE THE REPORTING, SARA
AND ELIE.